if jaws and piranha 3d had a kid it'd
kind of be like this movie a little bit
[Music]
shark Night 3d if you have seen the
trailer to this movie or even seen the
poster or heard the title you know
exactly what this movies about it's
about sharks that eat people namely a
bunch of college students who went out
to a cabin and have a good time on the
weekend I was watching this movie and I
was like what happened to the day when
people took the shark movies seriously
you know like in Jaws when
thirty-year-olds actually played 30 year
olds not college students now everything
exists for the sake of getting eaten by
a shark I didn't dislike shark Night 3d
as much as I disliked piranha 3d they're
both implausible impractical movies that
exist for the sake of you know watching
people get shredded it's almost like
shark Night 3d took itself a little more
seriously for the sake of not relying on
porn stars and you know floating dicks I
get eaten I got to give the movie that
and there were a couple of other
variables they didn't just have to worry
about sharks there were other you know
there are a couple lunatics in the movie
too but for the most part it's sharks
that's what we came to see we didn't
come to see like weird hillbillies it
should be called shark night and
Hillbillies in 3d now as for the 3d in
the movie there are actually two aspects
of 3d the scenes that are not underwater
in which the 3d looks like you know it
looks pretty good it looks like a 3d
movie but then the movie goes from 3d
above the water to 3d below the water
and below the water the depth of field
is so much more sharp that it makes your
eyes just go crossed immediately and
you're like ah dude my eyes need to
adjust what did you do like you know
those 3d pictures from 1995 imagine
taking those and putting it like right
up to your face your eyes go like that
cross great if the 3ds more pronounced
and it looks cooler if you can get past
the pain in your eyes but you know how
it's really scary when you don't see the
shark you just see a person and get
stuck under the water and they die like
in Jaws it works and a movie like this
where it just relies on Gore you might
as well just show the shark just shred
someone in half but it doesn't always do
that does it a couple times at the end
of the movie but for the most part you
see the person gets sucked underwater
and they're struggling with something
that's not there I would rather have
seen the shark maybe I'm a morbid
bastard I don't know so it's almost like
this movie was confused wanted to take
itself seriously in some parts and it
didn't in other scenes I mean the title
itself shark Night 3d you don't take
that movie seriously so just go nuts
with it we just cut back on the porn
star some floating dicks like piranha 3d
and you'll be fine
but as you'd expect it's a good time if
you're drunk and now it's a party sharks
there's not really another kind of
writing you can give this movie you
imagine that movies like a good time no
alcohol required
that would blow your mind and blow my
mind all I know is through his this
hillbilly dating there dude freaking me
out more than the Sharks did I was like
that's the real problem right there take
care of that guy shoot a harpoon through
his neck he was just so what's your
favorite water-based shark slash
creature slash anything in the water
that's out to eat people kind of movie
comment below let me know and as always
and this never changes if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]